hey everyone welcome back my name is
Nick Korolev and welcome to CH at we are
graciously hosted on cloud on air and
today we are gonna be talking about a
super exciting subject startups so here
with me is Jason Jason on the startup
team you want to introduce yourself real
quick - hi everyone my name is Jason
Scott I'm the startup program leader for
the west coast here on Google cloud
awesome well thank you so much Jason
it's always great to have other
teammates other Googlers joining us we
have a special surprise and that later
this episode we actually have a customer
lift igniter who's gonna be jumping in
and talking about their experience with
the startup program but Jason startups
are an exciting breed I mean they're
lightning fast they make changes on a
dime they're hypersensitive to costs and
they want to be on the bleeding edge so
I'm just curious I didn't really know
that GCP had to start a program until
quite recently so what is the startup
program and what is it that you do yeah
so the startup program I would say
they're kind of three big ways that we
support startups I would say the first
is access so as you know access to
product whether those be cloud products
or firebase or Maps API is if they're
doing cool things with maps or just even
access to resources and technical
resources as well so we do a lot of
technical office hours and one-on-one
architecture reviews things like that
for startups but I would say one of the
biggest things that we provide is just
the community so we love connecting
startups that are building things on GCP
and connecting them to the outside
community so here in on the west coast I
love I love connecting startups to
partners that we have in the in the
ecosystem so accelerators and VCS as
well as just Googlers who are really
passionate about working with startups
that's cool I mean it's it's basically
all about who you know sometimes in the
startup world so if Google is able to
help me get connected or help my startup
get connected with Googlers and partners
and and VCS and all that that's really
awesome so just why should a startup
kind of consider going with maybe the
GCP started program as opposed to kind
of like jumping in on
without the CCP program or anything like
that yeah um I mean I fundamentally I
would say Googlers just love startups
and Google I think fundamentally also
love startups and I think whether it be
through our commitment to open source
and you see that what kubernetes and
with tensorflow but also through just a
lot of our activities that we do as a
whole we've really believed in kind of
the one Google and I and I am always
pleasantly surprised when I'm able to do
an event and I not just have people at
cloud but how people come in from other
teams across Google to also support
startups and I think Google's one of
those few places where you can do that
where you actually have people that are
helping startups with all of their
infrastructure and all in all of their
products throughout their business model
and throughout their stages of growth
that's true I mean at Google cloud is
obviously one aspect of maybe hosting
your application running your
applications somewhere in the cloud but
there's a lot of other aspects for
instance like the advertising and the
Google search and all that exactly which
I feel like it's startup probably needs
some guidance on or could definitely use
some guidance on so for sure I mean it's
overwhelming you can imagine being that
one person kind of getting your company
off the ground and it's really nice to
have a centralized resource I would say
and I love that part of my job and being
able to be that centralized resource
first founder or developer that's
looking to get something off the ground
that's cool that's cool so I know that
your base I the west coast but startups
too aren't just based on the west coast
there's a lot of them out of the San
Francisco Bay but they're all across the
world so do we have a startup program
like resources to help them across the
u.s. across the world stuff like that
for sure so that I have counterparts
across the world and we are covering
startups anywhere if you're a developer
or startup on any continent we have
someone that could be a resource for you
and we have Googlers who can be a
resource for you we also do a lot of
things digitally so you're able once
you're in our program to sign up for
digital office hours and things like
that as well so if you are in a really
remote location we're we try our best to
get you those resource and get you
access to that yeah no matter where you
are hopefully we can help so yeah that's
cool and I've definitely helped with
some of these office hours in the past
so it's always exciting to get engaged
with a start-up
find out how they're using some some
product on the absolute bleeding edge
maybe something that we didn't even
think about for one
products machine learning or big data or
cog functions are really anything but
it's definitely exciting to sit down
with the customer and kind of help guide
them on maybe some best practices
lessons learned and stuff like that so
cool and I guess this is kind of a bias
question because we're Google but I just
have to ask so why GCP for startups why
GC / startups um I mean I kind of
alluded to a little bit earlier but I
think we really are kind of made to grow
with the startup and I would say look
even our program is designed for we have
a pre program option for people who are
just getting started thinking about do
they want to do they want to even do
they have an idea and that gives you a
little bit of credits a little bit of
product support to really just kind of
play
let's say with our products and then we
grow with you and I think we're really
set up to do that through all of our
state is our program from start to start
to surge and once you get to surge and
we'll hear a little bit from lift
ignited later there's also a lot of
opportunities to just get your name out
there and kind of do things like this be
in front and picture startup and talked
about your startup to a broader audience
so I think we're able to really grow
with you both infrastructurally but then
also as a founder which i think is
something we believe really
fundamentally a cool yeah that makes
perfect sense
and then I guess final question while we
have you here is what kind of success
stories do you have that you can share
about startups on GCP so many weird
rights I mean everyone knows kind of the
snapchat story so I won't start there
but I I meet founders every single day
that are doing really cool things from
leveraging machine learning to better
diagnose patients with chronically ill
diseases all the way to also leveraging
our vision API is to better diagnose
disease crops and help farmers to fun
things there's a not that those were fun
but so fun things like such as helping
using firebase to help users that aren't
technical build apps that are native on
both iOS and Android I think you just
encounter everything and I'm excited to
hear from lifting a door how they're
leveraging our products but every day I
hear a new exciting kind of idea that of
a developer our founder is doing I'm in
the way that they're leveraging our
products to do that yeah and you touched
on something really important I think is
that Google cloud will grow with you and
you highlighted snapchat I mean snapchat
at one point was a startup maybe you
could argue that it's still as a
start-up maybe but yeah when they first
started with Google they were much
smaller than they are today obviously
but yeah we scaled with them and now
they were able to host their application
on us and so it's it's really fantastic
well I really believe that the proof is
in the pudding and and that actually
talking to the startup kind of kind of
proves our point and we can get some
really good nuggets of information and
knowledge from them so Jason I'd like to
thank you for for joining us on this sea
chat and then as we kind of transition
to lift ignitor i'll ask that engineer
come on on the camera awesome well thank
you yeah thank you and just as a
reminder to our audience we do have at
the bottom of this page a resource for
you to ask questions and so we'll be
able to answer those questions live
later at the end of the segment and ask
those questions about startups or add
service questions about lyft igniter and
then as one final point make sure that
you keep watching the webinar because as
Jason hinted we do have a special
program at the very end where you might
be able to get some GCP startup credits
so very cool engineer thank you for
joining us and you are the founder of
lifting matter that's really awesome
would you mind introducing yourself and
maybe sharing what lifting guider does
absolutely thanks happy thanks for
having me here Nick so you know pleasure
to be here so --lifts igniter is a
machine learning personalization company
and the best way to think about that is
you think of a site like YouTube where
every time you watch a video a few
videos are picked automatically for you
to watch next and most of you who's you
know spend time on YouTube know how
addicting it is and but what you may not
realize is behind the scenes there is
this enormous ly powerful you know
artificial intelligence software that is
speaking videos for you from a pool of
billions of videos and it's doing it for
every single user that
comes to the site it's an enormous ly
difficult problem but once you do it
right if you can't pick the right video
that a user is interested in watching
next you will create that addictive
experience which means end users have a
much more satisfying experience on
YouTube and it also means that they will
spend less time on other sites so it's a
critical thing for the website owners to
have and it's a-you know it's an
important component of the user
experience and the only way to make this
possible at scale in this attention
economy is to have intelligence behind
the scenes which is only possible
through machine learning and you know
more recent AI techniques so that is you
know what lifting Nider tries to bring
to the rest of the world which may not
be able to you know have you know bill
you know hire the same kind of engineers
as a Google or a Facebook can or build
the kind of infrastructure that they can
you know that's an interesting point so
essentially you're taking the the
concept behind YouTube's recommendations
and all that and then applying them to
really all of your customers out there
right exactly you know the concept of
personalization has been around since
the start of the internet you know you
had personalization companies even in 99
what has truly changed is and we always
knew that in order to do personalization
you need to build intelligence at scale
and what has changed recently is massive
breakthroughs in machine learning
massive breakthroughs in cloud computing
I mean in the presence of cloud
computing solutions and amazing
infrastructure has made it possible for
startups like us to actually building
solutions and make it available at a
reasonable price to the rest of the
world although and this is why you know
the first the genesis of such solutions
happened in companies like Google and
Facebook which had the absolute state of
the art and infrastructure and some of
the best engineers massive resources but
now it's come to a point with these
waves of advances in machine learning
and cloud computing that it can be made
available
to the water via startups like lifting
NATO that's really awesome and and it's
so exciting that you guys are pretty
much on the breaking edge of doing this
and it's really thanks to machine
learning so I guess some of the basic
questions is how or when did you found
lifts igniter and kind of why did you
get into the space in the first place
yeah I mean so you know Alyssa Geiger
actually has an interesting
janessa story so I was at I was part of
Google the Google research team that
built out several of the major
personalization systems at Google
including that of YouTube so I got to
see firsthand what a massive impact you
know true machine true real-time machine
learning at scale can have on customer
satisfaction on you know business
metrics for you know the website owners
and so I felt like this technology had
to be made available you know at a price
point to a reasonable price point for
the rest of the world and frankly so
this was about four years ago and you
know and you know so basically that was
that was a story like that was the
inspiration some of the breakthroughs
that happened in companies inside Google
and we saw similar breakthrough is
happening at Facebook you felt like this
needed to be made available to the rest
of the world cool and then from a high
level how exactly does it work yeah so
you know so there's a lot of things
going on behind the scenes but what we
do is we look at two kinds of data we
look at user activities on the site very
very carefully and then we look at you
know the kind of signals that you can
extract out of the content itself you
know through NLP through image features
extraction through like video analysis
and then we and taking all this data
this data becomes very large very
quickly of course and you know so do
what we need to do with this data is
actually you know even more difficult so
there are three things that we need to
do we need to do sophisticated modeling
in order to be able to guess what a you
know a complex creature like a human
being
want next yeah we need to do this
modeling at scale because as we discuss
you know the data blows up really fast
and finally the third pieces we need to
do it really really fast in the order of
100 milliseconds or you know per visit
and do these three things scalability
complex modeling and real time they
don't really go well with each other
unless you have built fantastic and you
have access to fantastic infrastructure
fantastic you know mathematical
algorithms so we kind of put all that
together and what ends up happening is
you have a truly dynamic experience on
the website so when a user comes like a
site like YouTube they might be showing
you know sports on the top row but you
might be interested in music right now
and then a few clicks the algorithms
have figured out you're in the mood for
music so when you go back to your
homepage the first row is now showing
music you know so that kind of
intelligence that can dynamically
personalize every element it's possible
only when you combine like really
sophisticated modeling using user
behavior and content at scale in real
time I'm always fascinated with machine
learning use cases because it seems like
machine learning sometimes can solve
everything I mean obviously it can't so
I just wanted to hear your opinion what
and your application has machine
learning worked really well with and
then maybe what are some of the
challenges that you've had with machine
learning where machine learning might
not be like the best use case absolutely
so you know machine learning if you can
focus and narrow down a use case and
gather enough data for it machine
learning can be a great solution and so
you know it's it's it's it's funny like
machine learning has you know there's so
much you know so much buzzer on machine
learning now but there are and it can
you know infuse and improve almost every
product but you can be infused and you
know every product but it's there are it
it it does it has to it has to fit in
natural grooves nicely so for instance
there aren't you know be like machine
learning can't suddenly predict that you
know a certain dressed someone wore on
in a you know on an Oscar night is going
to resonate with a lot of users which a
human ear which a marketer or you know
someone who has domain expertise might
you know have a lot of intuition for so
it it's imperative that you know machine
learning algorithms Asian crunch a lot
of data really fast to complicated
things be paired with human intelligence
which can make these leaps through you
know last you know last more experience
and more sophisticated you know
cognitive models that you know
algorithms cannot do typically so we are
really I would say scratch you know the
beginnings of where sophistic where we
are from a sophistication perspective
and and so it still needs to be a big
partnership between humans and machine
learning to be truly driving in the
value yeah that's a really interesting
point I find that machine learning can
be a little bit challenging to get into
specifically for some of those reasons
and it's it's awesome that Google's kind
of releasing more and more products like
Auto ml and stuff like that that can
kind of meet the user halfway and and
not just provide an ml API but kind of
allow them to put some of their secret
sauce on their customization on top of
it but you're absolutely hit on a ripe
on the correct point in that in order to
do machine learner you have to have a
whole bunch of data in order to train
the model but not only do you need the
data but you need to be able to have
data that's that's clean that's been
sanitized and so some of those processes
have to have to be aided by by people by
ETL processes stuff like that so yeah
it's actually a lot of work to you know
to get the integration right because
algorithms are very sensitive to
feedback data and you know so a lot of
things have to fall into place before it
can work when it does work it works like
magic but you know we're still as I said
just scratching the surface and they're
like lots lots more - a lot more things
that can't be done by machine
and that can be done yeah cool and is
there a success story that you're able
to share with us yeah absolutely
you know just this is you know a very
common exam
example of where how we are used by our
customers so this is you know this is a
site which has a lot of high end fashion
items and we are personalizing a grid of
products that are shown to a user
this grid chain is fully responsive as
the user navigates through the site as
they click on different items within you
know sub-second area like within
actually 100 millisecond when they
revisit the grid after navigating the
site for a little bit of time it is
completely changed to reflect that the
kind of mood they might be in the kind
of reference is that the algorithm has
inferred the user might be in when you
do that you see the kind of you know
results that you know you should see
here like improvements and user
engagement the time they spend on the
site 50 percent or and you know dollars
they spend on the site because they're
finding the products they want by you
know double-digit percentage of yeah
sure huge yeah I like your example of
essentially user initially go to the
side and they see all sorts of different
items dresses shirts purses all that but
then when they start clicking on some
purses you can kind of infer that the
user is maybe more searching for purses
rather than all their other clothing
items so that make sense
yeah and you know it's important to do
this in real time because you never
really know who the user is even if
they've logged in it by the way 90% of
the users are not logged in and even if
they are logged in it might be their
spouse or it might be their kids using
it so their mood right now cannot be
inferred by two years old worth of
purchasing data so it has to react in
real-time the best intent of the best
signal for what a user is going to do in
the next five seconds is given by what
they did in the last five seconds and
you have to build a truly real-time
machine learning solution gotcha
that makes sense cool and are you able
to walk through some of your
architecture with us yeah absolutely and
you know just to give you you know to
give you a sense of the scale we're at
with you know a necessity it's like
pretty sophisticated architecture we're
you know we're processing tens of bill
of user activities per month which you
know this is no small feat yeah it is it
is you know there used to joke like at
some point we we were processing more
than a billion page views per engineer
in our in our in our company so there
you know things that were absolutely not
possible yeah like ten years ago yeah so
we're definitely leveraging all the
latest technology in a very critical way
but we process you know tens of
thousands of events per second we score
like millions of content per second to
figure out the right you know preference
is the right match for a user and we
have billions of signals that we analyze
and you know this all of this requires
like a really you know sophisticated
architecture and you know where you know
which I can describe in a second so yeah
let's do that so so beer beer on GCP
obviously and you know we use a variety
of you know pieces of their technology
this is a highly simplified diagram more
arrows yeah there are there are a lot
more pieces a lot more arrows but it's
already shows how you know we critically
use several insurances it was so we have
as I've said in probably the most common
word I've used is real time so we have
lots of pieces to make as much of the
processing in real time as possible so
for instance we have a plaster an order
scaling cluster of front-end computing
instances which receive a mass you know
this firehose of events yeah then we
process them through the Google cloud
pub/sub message queue and then behind
the consumers of those message queue are
these real-time jobs that are also on
auto scaling clusters one thing we use
here is to keep costs low which is you
know critical for startups as we use
instances which which preemptable
instances which are much more cheap
because our real time jobs they they
require less strict guarantees because
it's a statistical system
so if there is a little bit of loss of
data that's fine for the machine
learning algorithm so we can keep you
know flexible preemptable cluster
running all of that data goes into our
data store which is you know a core
piece of our infrastructure with
supports you know you know hundreds of
thousands of read writes per second and
that is built on a cluster of Google
computing instances we use a variety of
cloud storage we use bigquery very
critically I think personally think big
query is a fantastic piece of software
it has eliminated
you know several quarters worth of
development that you would have had to
do otherwise in order to create real
time analytics it's a great tool for
non-technical customers or non-technical
members of our company to analyze data
as well and finally from the machine
learning side we built a lot of the
machine learning in-house but we also
use some of you know some deep learning
api's like for vision and NLP for which
google has you know the state of the art
the best api is around and at a very
reasonable cost hmm so I'm just a little
bit curious it looks like a lot of your
machine learning happens in GCE rather
than maybe like the quad machine
learning engine so would you mind just
adding some context of like why you went
with one versus the other
just serious yeah some of it is historic
gold you know we as we will cover you
know we weren't originally on GCD and in
fact we started before a Google cloud
was a bigger prize and second so we had
to build a lot of our own machine
learning some of it is because we do
very custom machine learning solutions
which mean which are not available as
free tools but that said we use a lot of
you know we use some ready-made api's we
use a lot of the tools like tensorflow
and a variety of some other open source
and I think as we move ahead we're going
to use way more of the machine learning
tools at Google and in fact I think you
know this might be my segue to like
there's a story behind us moving images
yeah we like one of the reasons we are
excited about Google cloud we made the
transition to Google cloud is you know
having been at Google I know first hand
what fantastic infrastructure they have
but also that they are some of the
leaders they have some of the best
machine learning they're like by far I
think you know the best machine learning
technology in the world and we want to
have a piece of that we are a machine
learning company we don't want to you
know compromise on that and so so we
absolutely believe and very very excited
try some of the new hardware some of the
new open source and the new services
that Google Cloud is releasing cool yeah
it's always interesting hearing the
advancements that Google is coming out
with specifically around machine
learning and big data
I mean cloud necks which happened
recently I feel like maybe a quarter of
the announcements had machine learning
because it seems like machine learning
is coming to every single product that
we have and it just makes sense so yeah
it's really interesting I'm a little bit
curious about your story from migrating
from another cloud provider on to GCP
how was the migration and any kind of
lessons learned and stuff yes so you
know pieces we started lifting out about
four years ago and Google cloud was you
know it wasn't a much more restricted
form then and you know major provider
was AWS and we we it was it was not a
difficult choice at that point and then
fast forward to some time you know early
last year you know we we were compelled
by a lot of the offerings we you know
first of all we were very excited that
Google was taking the cloud business
seriously because for variety reasons I
think it makes a lot of sense you have
you know some of the best infrastructure
it's some insane infrastructure
internally at Google and making that
available to the rest of the world is
this you know this is an idea that
excites me it appeals to me in some
extent lyft igniter had that same spirit
of taking and so so we were compelled to
take a very close look and then you know
and there were a few reasons that
convinced us that the migration even
though the migration is gonna be very
painful for startups you know it still
makes sense you know and that's a big
big decision coming from like a series a
level company to me and there's the main
things are you know the bet on machine
learning happened that Google is going
to remain the leader and there
expose some of the best technology
machine learning technology and cloud
the second thing was they were we were
very impressed by the people we
interacted with under commitment to
helping startups and you know startups
need money startups need great access to
great technology but another thing they
really would like is you know marketing
exposure and you know it's events like
this for instance you know Google has
been phenomenal like we've had ton of
exposure through blogs through you know
conferences through events like this but
you know getting our message out so that
was very very compelling for us and that
was something we were willing to you
know take a hit on engineering
productivity for a few months doing a
migration for there were a few other you
know business reasons like a lot of our
customers our e-commerce customers and
you know they're not really comfortable
you know being with vendors that are
completely hosted on AWS for obvious
reasons and there are a few other things
like obviously the infrastructure on
certain pieces was more exciting the
pricing was friendlier in in many ways
and so all of these reasons together you
know we just made a call and you know I
think we're very glad that we actually
made that decision cool well hats off to
Jason team I mean the startup program is
phenomenal working with customers and
and everything so that's that's really
awesome
can you share some of the maybe things
that lifting diner is gonna be coming
out with and in the future yeah
absolutely so we you know when we
initially started you know I'm a machine
learning you know PhD by you know from
my in my background it was it was all
about like machine let's make build the
best algorithms what we realized is you
know there are limitations of the
algorithms there are things that are
human this does much better and in order
to build a full-fledged product we need
to kind of balance those two things so
we have this concept of augmented
intelligence so we have these machine
learning algorithms but working for you
working as tools that market our skin
use the same you know much in the same
way that you know Google Cloud is making
tools available rather than solutions to
you know replace human beings so that is
our focus and we're coming up with a lot
of tools for technical as well as
non-technical people to leverage the
sophisticated machine learning get use
the insights from them use them as tools
to achieve their ends so so that's
that's you know one of the most exciting
things we have a railroad man that's
cool yeah that's awesome
and then I guess last question for you
before we jump into some of the Q&A is
how do people get in touch with lyft
igniter I've heard that you're you're
looking for maybe some new people to
join the team and obviously looking for
customers so yeah we we have unit so if
you have if you want to test the product
you know just send us shoot us an email
in for a lyft igniter we will get on a
call with you right away we have a lot
of information on the website as well
and we're obviously you know looking for
amazing machine learning back in
front-end engineers marketing as well as
non-technical folks on the sales and
marketing site so just drop us a note
add jobs at lyft igniter and we will get
back to you cool well engineer thank you
so much for spending the time with us
we're gonna take a quick break for all
the questions that have been submitted
so we can compile them into one slide
and then we're gonna have you and Jason
back to kind of go over some of those
answers so thank you very much
appreciate it thanks so much Nick
you
all right everyone well
again Jason Scott started a program
leader on the west coast here at Google
cloud and we have internal here founder
of lyft igniter and we're back for a few
questions
so uh you want to just kick it off sure
awesome so first question we have so now
that lift recliner has been on GCP for a
while are there some things you wish are
known from the beginning yeah that's a
great question I think definitely you
know we received a lot of help from the
Google team while migrating but there
were a few things we just could have
planned better during migration so
anyone who's planning to migrate from
let's say AWS or some other cloud
provider to GCP a you know be you know
it's good to probably dive down into
some of the technologies which may look
similar for instance Genesis which is a
message queue on AWS versus Google cloud
pub/sub there are some subtle
differences that can change you know how
much money it costs you change how much
you know what kind of throughput you're
achieving so both on the technical as
well as expense side you might want to
redo your code in a certain way in order
to best use the new technology that
you're migrating to so they were so some
of the things we thought were
straightforward may not be so it's good
to take a closer look while doing the
migration and that's that was the theme
behind like several pieces like for
instance the streaming jobs as well when
we went from streaming jobs which were
mostly self you know it was managed by
us to like cloud dataflow there were
some differences which were a pleasant
surprise and there were some others
which were you know unexpected and we
had to kind of maneuver but if he had
just known a few more details in advance
it would have helped with a smoother
transition well we made it which is a
second question that came from out is
any words of wisdom I guess aside from
the one that you just mentioned for
other aspiring startups and founders out
there yeah I mean you know there is a
lot of wisdom out there I don't think
you know it so I would I would strongly
recommend
looking at Y Combinator's content we
actually went through Y Combinator and
if you are a first-time founder I would
say that's one of the best places you
look up there startup school advice look
at their course notes look B and you
know I would strongly recommend going
through that program as well but beyond
that you know it's startups are
exhilarating it's like you're gonna live
life in a more intense way and so you
know brace for it but it's gonna be
worth it awesome third and you mentioned
the challenges of migration already but
what are some of the benefits and
challenges some of the other benefits
and challenges that literally never
faced on GCP throughout your journey
yeah so you know the benefits again you
know we kind of touched upon these
issues like the pricing is much
friendlier it helps us reduce planning
and some extra overhead it's easier to
sell to some of our customers again the
e-commerce customers some of the tools
are just a little bit more
developer-friendly I keep hearing this
from a lot of our developers like the
the permission system is you know a
little more friendly the you know Google
out pops up it has a lot of cloud
dataflow there are very well designed
[Music]
services which reduces the coding
complexity so you know there have been
like innumerable little things like that
which we really like and then of course
access and some big things whereas like
bigquery which is you know phenomenal
piece of in you know it's a product
infrastructure it has simplified a lot
of our product and it has cut down our
dev time by several months
totally worth the price and some of the
artists you know our scaling logic etc
which has also worked pretty well for us
and so that was some of the benefits the
challenge is again you know some more
better research before doing the
migration could have created helped us
create a better plan for migration and
then the other thing is you know it's
Google cloud has some fantastic features
but it's also there are some rough edges
like not many but some like for instance
a load balancer went down a few weeks
ago and then and then there were I think
some minor bits and pieces like we had
there was just a little bit more
monitoring less monitoring metrics that
are available which which is kind of
important for us too because we have
strong isolated our customers again
nothing
these aren't showstoppers these are all
things you can work work around and I'm
sure these will improve very quickly
given the pace at which Google cloud has
you know improved over the over the last
few years yeah thank you for being
candid yeah I guess the last question is
one that I can take it says if I'm a
start-up how do I get engaged with
Google so I think with that I would love
to let everyone know that as a viewer or
as a listener to this you're all
eligible to join our startup program at
our start tier which is kind of our
early stage tier for our program that
includes $3,000 in cloud credits and
firebase credits as well as a lot of
other benefits G suite if you're on that
as well as the support the technical
score that we mentioned earlier as well
and yeah with that I would like everyone
to stay tuned for our next session which
is Google sheets tips and tricks to
boost productivity something I
definitely will also tune into I'm
coming to you live from New York and
with that thank you in general for
coming thank you to everyone and for
listening in and we'll see you next time
you